my name is Noah planaski and I'm a
geochemist where a lot of my research is
focused right now is trying to
understand what controls carbon dioxide
levels and how we can change carbon
dioxide levels over the next hundred
years to have greater climate stability
I originally went to school as a
geologist and I thought I was going to
wander or Surface just making
observations in the Rock record but I
found that most of the questions that I
was interested in were better solved
through geochemical tools and through
geochemical modeling then field
observations alone
the type of geochemistry that I do is
understanding how individual reactions
occurring in organisms within soil or
within the ocean will affect the
atmosphere will affect climate on a
global scale
[Music]
for me what's going to be the next step
in geochemistry and what's going to make
geochemistry more impactful is the core
of my research program which is a better
integration of field observations novel
geochemical tools and tying that into a
robust and meaningful quantitative
framework of course it makes sense to
have all of those components combined
having a research program that does that
well and that ensures that all of those
parts are greater than what they would
be individually is I think what's going
to be the important component of moving
forward our understanding over the next
decade
foreign